das Thema über das heute jeder Deutsche
eigentlich spricht bewegt auch mich das
Kanzler Machtwort was mich nämlich
verwundert ist so ein bisschen der grüne
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck der
empfindet jetzt nämlich die von Scholz
getroffene Entscheidung als ein Weg mit
dem ich gut arbeiten und leben kann das
sagt der Habeck auf jeden Fall am
Montagabend in den all die Tagesthemen
das klang auf dem Parteitag der Grünen
am 14 Oktober nur drei Tage vor dem
Kanzler Rums nun ja ein ganz wenig
anders hören wir doch mal rein
wahrscheinlich ist es auch nicht falsch
zu vermuten dass die Botschaft
eigentlich war die doch zurück zu
Atomkraft das ist falsch und das wird
auf keinen Fall mit uns passieren nicht
mit der Bundesregierung nicht mit den
Grünen in der Bundesregierung und nicht
mit Steffi und nicht mit mir
ja das verstehe ich jetzt nicht so ganz
erfahren heute verstehen sie das oder
sind die Grünen eigentlich wenn man es
platt sagt ein wenig verlogen ja das
haben wir doch schon das ganze Jahr
feststellen können
und wenn man sich anschaut welche was
die Wirkung jetzt dieses Machtwort des
Kanzlers ist wir gucken ja aus in der
Industrie jeden Tag uns die Strompreise
an und seit gestern ist der Strompreis
um 10 € Cent gesungen das zeigt uns was
uns dieses gehampelte der Grünen in
diesem Jahr eigentlich gekostet hat ja
es waren gestern noch 30 Cent jetzt sind
es 20 Cent in der Spitze und wenn ich
das mal so hochrechne darf man einen
nicht tun aber ich tue das mal auf ein
Jahr hoch Rechner reden wir über 50
Milliarden 50 Milliarden die Grünen
haben uns 50 Milliarden natürlich weil
ja am Ende das fing doch an mit wir
haben keinen Stromproblem dann hörten
wir streckbetrieb geht nicht
funktioniert nicht bringt nichts dann
wurde gesagt zwei Kernkraftwerke und
dann im niedersächsischen Wahl Kampf
wurde wurden die Bürger hinter die
Fichte geführt das hat dann ja auch
geklappt und jetzt ist auf einmal alles
wieder gut und am Ende muss man
feststellen 50 Milliarden weniger in den
Taschen der Bürger und der Unternehmen
und das kostet Arbeitsplätze am Ende es
kostet unsere Arbeitsplätze weil wir
konkurrieren ja mit Strompreisen in
Amerika von zwei Euro Cent und in China
von drei Euro Cent und deswegen muss man
jetzt schon sagen
diese allgemeine Zufriedenheit die sich
da jetzt so breit macht
da muss man auch ein bisschen vor warnen
denn
das reicht hinten und vorne nicht ja
darüber sprechen wir auch gleich noch
wir bleiben einmal noch bei Herrn Habeck
Herr Kronberg da frage ich jetzt
natürlich sie als FDP-Politiker sie
haben jetzt bestimmt große Freude daran
sich über die Grünen aufzuregen sind
aber ja mit denen eine Ampel aber meine
Frage ist bleibt dabei ist diese
Götterdämmerung bei den Grünen jetzt
nicht eigentlich scheinheilig also
erstmal Frau Schink freue ich mich nicht
das wäre sicherlich fehl am Platz ich
freue mich Entscheidung des Kanzlers das
ganz sicher die freuen sich nicht dass
man ein kleines Machtwort mit den Grünen
gesprochen wurde naja also wir haben
sehr unterschiedliche Ausgangspositionen
FDP und Grüne in dieser Frage das ist
richtig aber uns eint auch die
Überzeugung dass es falsch wäre zurück
in die Atomkraft zu gehen
wir sprechen ja jetzt nicht von einem
zurück in die Atomkraft sondern von dem
Weiterbetrieb für vier Monate das ist
das was der Kanzler jetzt entschieden
hat in ihnen schlagen ja wahrscheinlich
zwei Herzen das politikerherzen das
unternehmerherz würde ich jetzt mal
jetzt hören wir einmal auf Verfahren
heute der gesagt hat 50 Milliarden das
ist ja eine ganze Menge Geld als
Unternehmer sagen Sie also immer noch
nicht dass die Grünen vielleicht doch
ein bisschen auf dem Holzweg sind
wir haben die Frage nach der
Weiterbetrieb der Atomkraftwerke anders
beurteilt wir haben gefordert dass sie
weiter betrieben werden und so
Forderungen gingen auch darüber hinaus
was der Kratzer jetzt entschieden hat
insofern ist es auf jeden Fall ein guter
Kompromiss der gefunden wurde und damit
kommen wir über den Winter und wir
werden im Frühjahr schauen wie es
weitergeht da ist jetzt überhaupt keine
Notwendigkeit der Entscheidung zu
treffen oder fordern früher finden
können also und dann die 50 Milliarden
vielleicht für Pflege wir haben eine
ganz viele Felder in Deutschland offen
sind naja also ob die 50 Milliarden
wirklich so gespart worden wären das
vermag ich nicht zu beurteilen die der
Strompreis bildet sich auch nach dem
sogenannten Marit order Prinzip und die
teuerste Energiequelle das war ganz
Strom war Gas und die Gaspreise sind
sehr sehr hoch gewesen sind auch schon
stark wieder zurückgelaufen aber
sie hätten ein Stück weit niedriger
bleiben können wenn Frank
Kohlekraftwerke wenn man mehr man da
mehr Atomstrom zusätzlich am Markt
gehabt hätte das ist schon richtig aber
ich kann das nicht in Euro Ziffern und
im übrigen ganz ehrlich es wäre auch
vergossen in welches ist Schneefang
gestern nicht also ihr fahrt sie fühlen
sich eigentlich ganz wohl in der Ampel
oh ja selbstverständlich
wir haben natürlich im letzten Jahr im
Wahlkampf noch eine andere Konstellation
bevorzugt besprochen aber die stand ja
nicht zur Verfügung nach dem Wahltermin
und insofern ist es vollkommen richtig
dass wir jetzt aus der Mitte der
Gesellschaft heraus und aus der Mitte
der politischen Positionen heraus
Regierungspolitik mitgestalten können
das ist der Anspruch den wir vor der
Wahl angekündigt haben den wir haben und
den setzen wir jetzt durch und um das
ist ja auch eine gute Entscheidung
gefallen gestern grünen rüber zu
wechseln also ganze wohlwand hat hier
noch nie ein FDP-Politiker über die
Grünen gesprochen aber das überlasse ich
natürlich ihnen ist natürlich nett für
die Grünen auch
ein Parteitag ist ja nun auch nicht der
verlängerte Arm einer
Regierungskonstellation es ist sogar
wichtig dass auf Parteitagen die
Positionen der Parteien deutlich werden
damit man dann im Regierungsgeschäft
Kompromisse schließt so funktioniert
unsere Demokratie das ist anders als in
China wo der Parteitag irgendwie
klatscht vor der niedersachsenwahl
genauso da müssen die Grünen Wähler
sicher schon fragen ob sie da vielleicht
die Kehrtwende nicht ganz so gerne
mitgemacht hätten die Niedersachsen Wahl
wurde nicht an der entlang der Atomkraft
Frage entschieden die wurde aber
definitiv da besprochen es war ja nicht
so als hätte man gesagt wir können ihn
da nichts versprechen wir sagen dazu
nichts
die Grünen plakatiert mit AKW bye bye
das kann ich noch sehen weil ich bin in
Hamburg Nachbarstaat und damit haben sie
Wahlkampf gemacht und haben natürlich
dann auch ihr Klientel an die Urne
gebracht
das war ein klares Votum gehen die gerne
Energie bin aber doch ein bisschen
anderer Auffassung
zu Kernenergie die ganze ganz Europa
geht zurück in die Kerne Energie
Schweden überlegt die schon abgestellten
Kernkraftwerke wieder zu reaktivieren
auch das Stück für uns gut zu Gesichtern
wir haben noch drei Kernkraftwerke
deaktiviert werden können und die
Schweiz macht weiter Belgien hat wieder
aktiviert Holland will drei neue polen
will zwei neue wir sind da wirklich die
Geisterfahrer und man muss sich schon
fragen
will ja bis 2024 immerhin verlängern ja
das ist ja schon mal vernünftiger Anfang
weil wir doch wissen die Gaskrise wird
doch nicht im nächsten Frühjahr beendet
sein wir werden doch mit Ach und Krach
vielleicht mit den Speichern auskommen
wahrscheinlich eher nicht wenn es einen
kalten Winter gibt aber dann werden die
Speicher leer sein und dann werden sie
nicht mehr aufgefüllt wir dürfen nicht
vergessen wir haben bis August diesen
Jahres immer noch die gazprom-leitung
gehabt die den die die Speicher
mitgefüllt haben das heißt wir werden im
nächsten Jahr im September anfangen mit
halben gastspeichern und in der
Situation zu sagen ach tut ja nix dazu
wir machen einfach so weiter und stellen
die Kernkraftwerke ab und der Fehler ist
das dann Gaskraftwerke tatsächlich als
teuerste da haben sie völlig richtig
denn Recht den Preis bilden und deswegen
müsste man eigentlich jetzt sagen Gas
hat in der Verstromung überhaupt nichts
mehr zu suchen das muss daraus und wir
wissen ja aus der alten sozialliberalen
Koalition und der Helmut Schmidt dass
die Kernkraftwerke in Deutschland so die
sind designt worden sind so ausgelegt
worden sind dass sie ganz schnell hoch
und runterfahren können die können
nachts runterfahren wie nichts anderes
viel besser als Kohle viel besser sogar
als Gas das vergisst man immer wieder
das heißt die ideale Ergänzung auch für
erneuerbare die wir ja alle wollen
erneuerbare Wind und Sonne heißt die
Kernenergie darüber muss man mal
diskutieren in dieser Gesellschaft Herr
Konrad als Bürger wenn ich sie frage wie
sehen Sie denn die Kehrtwende der Grünen
vergleichbar es ist halt eine Art von
Kehrtwende von den maximalpositionen
jetzt zu einem ersten Kompromiss
innerhalb der der Ampel Koalition zu
kommen ich sehe allerdings die
Energiefrage aus der
nachrichtendienstliche Sicht auch noch
mal ein bisschen anders nicht nicht
fröhlicher ehrlich gesagt denn wir
argumentieren derzeit ja nur mit dem
Status Quo das heißt also wenn
unterstellen dass die Energieversorgung
so wie sie jetzt mit Ach und Krach
hergestellt worden ist dass sie so
bleibt jetzt denken sie bitteschön daran
dass wir das schöne Wort Hybride
Bedrohungen haben dass wir jetzt seit
Wochen die Händeringen und den Schutz
der kritischen Infrastruktur in den
Vordergrund stellen ja vor wem denn ja
nicht von vor den Umweltaktivisten sage
ich jetzt mal sondern letzten Endes und
das hat gestern übrigens haben die drei
nachrichtendienstchefs auch bei der
öffentlichen Anhörung vor dem
parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium für
alle Bürger auch sehr deutlich gesagt
das Risiko einer horizontalen Eskalation
des ukraine-konflikts nicht nur für die
Ukraine sondern auch für die
Unterstützer starten und eben auch für
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland er
besteht auch darin dass man im Winter
mal da oder dort nicht nur eine
Energiequelle einschränkt sagt man ganz
vorsichtig
das ist durchaus möglich das hat durch
entsprechende entweder an welche
Energiequellen denken sie da konkret
Kraftwerke abstellen zum Beispiel oder
Sie haben ja nordstream gehabt ohne
jetzt die Urheberschaft schon
präjudizieren zu wollen nicht aber Sie
können ja selbstverständlich andere
zulieferleitungen oder Sie können
Steuersysteme etc können sie ja durch
entweder mit der Cyber Network attack
oder aber eben mit ganz normaler
Sabotage als analoger als Sabotage
können sie ja das auch mal flachlegen
und dass die Dinge aufgeklärt worden
sind jetzt auch deutlich vor dem Ukraine
Krieg und relativ leicht aufklärbar sind
sollten wir auch nicht vergessen sie
können fast alle in kritische
Infrastruktur inzwischen im Internet
Recherche aus anderen Gründen der
Transparenz nicht nur der
Bürgerbeteiligung der
Raumordnungsverfahren
sie ist sie ist einfach da sie ist da
und sie hängt ab vom Kriegsverlauf in
der kleinen sie dürfen nicht vergessen
wir kommen ja später sowieso noch drauf
das ist mein Putin und designen werden
diesen Krieg nicht verlieren wollen
und solange sie diesen Krieg nicht
verlieren wollen werden sie wenn sie im
Felde wenn sie wollen nicht siegen
können danach sitzt derzeit ja gar nicht
richtig aus wenn Sie horizontal
eskalieren das sehen wir jetzt im
Augenblick schon bei der Ukraine nennt
man an den Fronten kann man nichts
bewirken also macht man jetzt genau das
man schädigt die Infrastruktur die
kritische Infrastruktur der Ukraine und
wenn herzelinski Schutz
bedauerlicherweise richtig gezählt hat
nicht erzählt ungefähr 30% der Zeit der
der Energieversorgung der Ukraine in den
letzten 10 Tagen durch russische
Luftangriffe zerstört eher eine Reaktion
auf die Krim nein ach so nein das war
ein netter Anlassen
sind gerade 1100 Ortschaften ohne Strom
aber das wissen sie vermutlich noch
besser
eigentlich ich kann nur bestätigen dass
30 Prozent der Energieinfrastruktur
wurden bestätigt und die Raketen
Angriffe ein Teil davon er hat die
Ukraine schon geschafft zu reparieren
aber eigentlich nicht alles kann man tun
und zum Beispiel gestern hat
jugendkraine
34 Drohnen erlebt die dann attackiert
wurden 30 davon hatten zum Ziel nur Kiew
25 wurden dann von der ukrainischen
Armee abgeschossen und dieser Terror dem
jetzt die Ukraine ja ausgeliefert ist
dass es nicht nur der Anfang sozusagen
das wird fortgesetzt und in Zukunft wird
der Russland alles tun und wirklich die
Infrastruktur noch mal stärker zu
beschädigen
das werden wir heute auch noch im näher
vertiefen sie selbst sind ja in der
Ukraine geboren jetzt leben sie ja in
Deutschland wenn sie sich das Kanzler
Machtwort heute anschauen wie haben Sie
darüber empfunden
das Kanzler Machtwort das erst
weiterlaufen lässt in Deutschland
mit Blick auf die Atomkraftwerke ich
glaube ich habe jetzt der Diskussion
zugehört ich muss sagen die Politik muss
immer den Kontext berücksichtigen und
Flexibilität zeigen man kann ich kann
mir vorstellen das was man eigentlich im
Programm sich vorgenommen hat muss man
auch in der Lage sein an den Kontext
anzupassen und mit Blick mit Blick auf
die Atomkraftwerke ich glaube keiner
konnte sich in Deutschland so was
vorstellen aber ich mehr als Außenseite
weil ich mich eher mit der Ukraine
beschäftige muss ich sagen die Politik
muss auch in der Lage sein den Kontexte
und neu Gegebenheiten zu berücksichtigen
und dementsprechend sich anzupassen